[Music]
good morning John it's Friday October
19th may be wondering why you can only
see my lips that is because if I don't
get really really really really really
close to the camera you can't hear me at
all because it is very loud on airplanes
hello airplane people but before I was
on an airplane I was in a car digging
and cue from our Australian secret
siblings I've created a kind of
travelogue this is Montana anyone who
experiences motion sickness should
likely step away from their YouTube this
is pretty much what we do in the car
anyone who can correctly identify the
song that I am currently singing will
win a nerdfighter dries and then I drop
the camera while still at Montana we
needed to relieve ourselves at the
world-famous 10,000 silver dollar casino
/ bar / restaurants / gift shop /
laundromat slashed RV / whatever else
but the real attraction was decides the
bathrooms is their gigantic collection
of silver dollars I don't know for some
reason that doesn't actually make sense
to anyone except maybe people who have
read Neil Gaiman American Gods people
just started giving them silver dollars
and they just started putting them up on
the walls until they had over 10,000 all
over the walls and this is what it looks
like and this is Abraham Lincoln and
this is the Hagen Montana post office
and we're driving again except wait wait
what's that exit zero that can only mean
one thing
alright a hole as the two turns out
Idaho's actually exactly like Montana
except uh more down a hill but then we
have to Washington which is different
because it has zips and zips has
sandwiches that have both meat and ham
and they also something that may very
well be the next wonder of the world and
that is this interlocking onion
Catherine and I played wishbone with it
and I wasn't easy on the bumps please
then we went over the paths into Western
Washington and that means grouse weather
and it also means that traffic and then
Oh worst traffic anyway expansion
improves traffic well I could show them
a couple of graphs just proving that
statement oh my god I have graphs
everybody a 16 year old nerdfighters out
there I would seriously suggest to you
that getting a car is kind of like
getting a tattoo
it seems cool when you're young but then
when you're old you still have it you
kind of have to have it for the rest of
your life that you really kind of start
to despise and resent it traffic makes
me cranky but we got there we didn't get
there - Kirkland Captain Kirk land
Washington well we get to hang out with
Jason we got to hang out crying
and then Jason drove us to the airport
at like 6 o'clock in the morning so
thank you Jason for doing that I don't
know if I would be that good of a friend
of our in your place so I have to go
because they totally took my computer
off John and I will see you on my
check out what gather dust out of the
SkyMall we need one of those